après un long week-end de l'ascension
les salariés de ji reprennent le chemin
du travail et peut se préoccupe du
déplacement ministériel
qu'attendez-vous de la venue de bruno le
maire jean rien à dire sur et vous
madame qu'est ce que vous attendez de la
venue de bruno le maire certains n'ont
pas d'avis sur la venue du ministre de
l'économie et des finances bruno le
maire d'autres ont peur des représailles
de la direction ils ont peur de faire
partie du pse du plan de sauvegarde de
l'emploi
si jamais ils viennent à s'exprimer à la
presse et les employés qui accepte de
nous dire quelques mots n'attendent pas
grand-chose cette visite je pense qu'
avoir l'état des choses et puis avoir
peut-être ce que le gouvernement peut
apporter mais bon je pense que la marge
de manoeuvre assez faibles on verra on
verra bien pas grand chose
parce que le plan est déjà annoncée donc
à votre avis pourquoi il vient j'adore
pas grand chose quoi je pense c'est plus
du pronom mur à 15 heures les syndicats
tiendront une assemblée générale puis
rencontreront le ministre
à 15h30